hello everybody I'm a drain I can't work
at anaconda and my day job is to work on
psychic land and I will be telling you
about the organization about around
circuit land psyche Lincoln trip there
is some changes that we've had and after
that I'll go over a few of the things
that we're focusing on right now some of
which have already released some of each
oran master and some of which are still
being boiled on the stove so let's talk
a little bit about the history of
scikit-learn it started in 2007 as a
google Summer of Code project and there
was a little bit of pause there and it
became more active after 2010 and since
2010 it's been on github and that is the
activity you see the it's a little bit
tricky to interpret that graph because
at the beginning the the pull requests
which are the contributions that are
ascent to the to the repo by the
contributors the commits were not
squashed meaning that if I was debugging
something and I had like da da da da
as my commit messages all of those would
be on the master log and one of the most
popular commit messages from back then
is pep 8 because obviously we forget to
format our code and we only care about
that when it's public and everybody sees
our code so let's look at the later
times to pass 3 years like we can look
at it a little bit better it doesn't
seem to change much but it actually does
the peaks are obviously the releases
there is more activity around any any
repo any library whenever there's a
release but also a lot of the comments
are not squashed around and went like
the ones that are related to the release
itself but when you look at the the idle
area around like between releases
there's a big difference like fifty and
a hundred that's a two-fold increase so
and when you look at it it started
around late like third quarter 2018 so
what happened then that was when in in
here foundation which was one of the
places that a lot of development cycle
and development was happening
historically they started to have
scikit-learn consortium in which they
were like okay we accept money in
donations and we will use that money to
fund full-time maintenance and now they
have three or four full-time maintenance
that was a huge boost other than that we
now have in total
other than the consortium we have the
Columbia University in New York whose
funding and the smoother and an analyst
mother has a fund which is supporting
Thomas and Nicola University of Sydney
is supporting Joel without whom we
wouldn't have this cycle and really he's
his great and anacondas funding me so
this this resulted in the whole repo
being a lot easier Anna and a lot of
players in the game we have obviously
the contributors who are some of some of
the contributors are the core
contributors some of them are hopefully
you and it's a lot but you get a lot of
noise some of some of it is noise a lot
of it is good contribution but it's a
lot of work we have the crew
contributors it grew we had through time
a lot of core contributors who were like
they had access to the repo but they're
not necessarily actives there are fewer
active core contributors then it grew
recently and then now we have the
sponsors and then what about the
decision making process it used to be
that unless there is a unanimous
consensus on any like anything it
wouldn't go in
so
it was an API change if he was a new
model being included on this all core
contributors agree on that it wouldn't
go in
as a result we had long-standing pool
requests things that were really easy
they were not big but they touch the API
anything that touches the API is
sensitive so they would be there for
five years and there was no decision
wait we didn't have any be DFL I also
didn't want to have any BDS all but in a
sense any core contributor was kind of a
btfo because everybody had like a veto
so we started drafting a governance
model this was I guess passed around
January this year we have contributors
who are the usual contributors we have
the core maintainer
these are the people who have access to
the repo and then we have a Technical
Committee the core devel anu core
developer is added to the team if
somebody nominates them and there is a
vote under ville passes any decision
that needs to be made there is a vote if
2/3 majority of the core maintainer is
agree on that it passes if some decision
is more controversial it doesn't have
2/3 majority a 50% of the technical
committee agrees on that then it passes
as a result of that we have managed to
pass a few changes and like there has
been a lot more changes recently
compared to the past because the there
is a consensus with this definition now
so what's now the scikit-learn basis
circuit Lincoln trip scikit-learn is an
organization there on github it has the
website it has the main repo and a bunch
of this sauce that are directly related
to circuit land package where a circuit
lankan trip is an organization under
which there are a whole bunch of other
repositories a lot of a bunch of
libraries they need to satisfy certain
constraints they need to be documented
they have CIA support Python 3 there's
like you learn compatible and there's
around 18 of them and if they don't it's
it so it was something that doesn't
really go into psychically
and but it's nice and the scikit-learn
community could use it it could go there
like scorch could be there it like the
benefit of that is that if it's if it's
not a very visible library it would give
it some visibility then on top of that
we thought okay we we get some pull
requests or some requests in general on
unsecured land regarding new models some
of them are really new models some of
them are old models that aren't included
in psychic land what do we do with them
the inclusion criteria is kind of pretty
high if if there is a paper backing the
model and it has at least like 300
citations then we may think about
including them but not everything gets
in but a lot of really good models are
out there that people could use what do
we do with them we decided to have
succulent extra which we moved a bunch
of those poor requests to a scale an
extra you can install that and these are
more experimental models there are newer
they're fancier they're more closer to
the bleeding edge of the science because
this guideline is like very traditional
machine learning and it's well
documented it's it's a we are we are
still working on having instead of you
still need to install it from source we
are thinking about having a binary
distribution for it on Conda and Popeye
but those are still in progress and
things that are included there some of
them are more popular than others like
SQL and pandas esculent doesn't really
support pandas it doesn't happen as in
pandas out it kind of does that with a
lot of overhead sometimes it works in
balance Lin if you have imbalanced data
metric land this leave is dynamic on
some models pretty cool and a whole
bunch over this so one thing that
happened with the decision making
process change was that okay now we need
like whenever we want to make a decision
we need a proposal to make that decision
those are the ones that we're calling
slip sake learning and has some
proposals the last one that we talked
and we it finally got accepted
was keyword only arcs a keyword only
argument it means that if I have look at
look at up there
I have SVM and NSCC and I'm passing the
two parameters positional as in that I'm
not saying C equals something and
currently call something the first line
is positional passing of the arguments
the the second one is keyword now Python
3 gives you the option of forcing
keyword only argument as in the user
cannot pass those parameters without
mentioning the name of the argument and
it's pretty useful for some of the
models that have a lot of arguments did
here optics for example it has those
many arguments the second variation is
not really understandable it's bad code
that's one part of it the other part is
that as maintainence whenever we wanted
to add a parameter to them to the to a
model we had to add that at the end of
the list not to break anybody's code
what that makes the whole system more
chaotic because the list of the
parameters is just random so now this is
now passed and we're gonna like through
some duplication cycle we're gonna force
everybody to pass to three parameters
with the name I'm gonna talk a little
bit about some of those slips more but
these are some of the things that I'm
gonna cover today as like whatever time
allows well we we dropped old pythons
it's Python 3.5 only and the next
release probably will be 3.6 plus only
we will be supporting the last three
parts on releases and by the time that
we release Python 3.8 we'll be out the
there's a nightly build now so if you
fancy using something from master you
can just install the nightly build and
it has its own documentation website
which is just def at the end instead of
stable and there has been a lot there's
a specific fund to imply improving the
parallelization and the performance of
the circular and pickling and a lot of
effort goes there and
nobody really sees them but they do
really need to get the credit for it
now the rest of them one thing we worked
a lot on was calling transformer it was
people really liked it it's really
useful you have a bunch of feel some of
them on new miracles some of them are
categorical you don't want to apply the
same kind of transformer on all the
fields you choose your categorical ones
for example here and then the or like
here I'm saying the title I want to do
con vectorizer the city I want to do a
100 coding and then that's the output
you get it's pretty neat and it's the
first the first transformer the first
model in circuit land that understands
pandas as in you can pass names of the
columns and it understands them before
that you would always have to pass it
the number of the column it was
experimental not anymore
needs a lot of bug fixes it was new kind
of for us because we needed to support
pandas it still has some issues working
on them and it's the post output feature
names so you can because when you do
those transformers it is important to
know ok which feature is what but what
were they before so you can get feature
names and it gives you that unless you
for example have passed through it
doesn't work so this is one of the
things that resulted in long discussions
about how do we support feature names as
in like how do we support pandas but one
of the things that when people people
mean different things when they say
pandas one of the things is feature
names what one of them what do we do
about that well we need to save a lot of
information about input and output
features to start with we need to know
the number of input features if you had
a transformer and like if you had a
transformer in a pipeline and they
change the number of features in the
pipeline there was no way for you to in
to investigate okay how many features
has each transformer received so these
are API changes so it's like the input
ones and the output ones but since they
are API changes there's gonna be slips
for them
a lot of discussions about that and they
are still in the process and then after
that we can have some feature names well
how do we do feature names one way was
to have pandas in pandas outs we need
something to to have the feature names
with it kind of when we were passing the
data through in a pipeline didn't want
to depend on pandas x-ray it was okay
but x-ray depends on pandas so that was
a no and so we are probably going to
have our own class which is completely
non PI compatible as soon as you do
anything on it it's gonna be an umpire
array but it has feature names in it and
there are already three slips in the
making and there is one more coming out
so it will take time but we were
actively working on it
sample properties sample weights are an
example of sample properties groups are
another example you may have data that
has gender race or any other attribute
attached to it those are your sample
properties that you don't want to use in
your model but you want to use maybe in
your scoring or for some other purpose
or you may have a nested
cross-validation and you have groups and
you want to pass those groups to the to
the to the cross-validation the inner to
inner one how do we handle those things
it's pretty hard the routing is really
hard to handle this is a really long
standing issue but we are close to
solving it stay tuned
resampler if you want a down sample or
up sample in your pipeline you can't do
that now you can have it you can have an
estimator yourself and do that and like
like those hacks really work but there
is an issue with it if I if I do if I
fit
I want to down sampler ops angle and I
have my resampler in my pipeline but if
I transform or if I call predict I don't
want to down sample if I give the test
data and I want to get the prediction
there shouldn't be any down sampling
there how do we handle that so we
probably will introduce a new verb
feature sample and there are two
proposals two competing proposals one of
them in the meta estimator the other one
is just example in a pipeline and we'll
see how that goes
we are going to define now what is
public API what is private API
up until now we've had documented API
and undocumented API we're gonna have
define it and be like whatever starts
with an underscore it's private the
issue with that is that we have a lot of
files that don't have underscore at the
beginning of them so you could import
logistic regression through a scale and
our linear model that logistic and it
sounds like it's the way you should
import it but no village the last
logistic is just a file name and there
are things that you can use but we
consider them private as and we don't
want to have them backward compatible I
think we want to be free to change the
API like one of the issues is that it
can be confusing for example a scale and
that linear model Doddridge is a module
as in is a file and then a scale and a
linear model that Ridge regression is a
function so to fix all of these issues
we're defining them and we're
deprecating we practically replace
renaming all the files adding an
underscore with a duplication cycle on
the models side the the histogram based
gradient boosting models this is what
you have an extra boost and light gbn by
Microsoft there was an initial
implementation of them in number then we
did that in so I thought it's still not
mature it's experimental
you need to explicitly enable that to
use it it's much faster than the
original gradient boosting models to the
point that if your data set is large
enough the old ones just don't work and
this one works really fast well it's not
mature for example I'm right now working
on adding sample weights to the model
but a lot more is coming we're adding
more losses sample weights as I
mentioned the categorical features to
instead of doing one hard encoding for
example a model to be able to handle a
categorical feature natively and it's
one of the few models that natively
supports missing values you don't need
to impute your data before passing it to
the model generalized linear models they
you can have
a loss function that is not the usual
one for example this is also a
long-standing one but as you see this is
a this is a trimmed-down version of
another PR which is adding over 2,800
lines of code
these are not easy to review and some of
the use cases are for example if your
output values are counts or frequencies
or they are positive valued and skewed
or you have a heavier tail and on your
on your upper distribution than a
Gaussian one the website we like as you
can imagine web development CSS
JavaScript none of that is our strong
suit so the website really looks bad we
recently revamped the whole thing it
looks much better but still working on
it and on top of that we are working on
better documentation get getting started
etc plus the new world of plotting and
maintaining them so you can let's say
you you you fit your model as usual now
you want to plot the RC now you can do
plot ROC curve and then show that it
works and now let's say you want to fit
another model and you want to add the RC
of that model to your plot you can do
that it like sets the axis and you can
plot it if this was the the first one we
started to design the API the plotting
API that we're happy with now this is in
and more plotting is in the making
imputation imputing the missing values
if you have missing values and you want
to fill them the the simple impute err
you can have different strategies like
the most frequent replacing with the
most frequent there are fancier one
coming
the I think they're matched so they are
in the nightly builds already some of
them are not released for example the
iterative in pewter tries to predict
each feature using the other features
and it fills the missing values as with
the output of the model that it learn
the KNN in pewter it does
KNN on the data and it fills the missing
values using that and you have the
missing indicator which means that if if
I impute my data it means that the the
data now doesn't have any missing values
but maybe the fact that the data was
missing is informative so another
transformer that I can apply in my data
is to just have this indicator it was my
data missing in the original data or not
it works like any other transform
permutation importance this is one of my
favorites and this is feature importance
is of the random forests so let's say I
fetch the Titanic data set from open ml
I use a bunch of the categorical
features and numerical ones and up there
I'm adding a random categorical feature
and a numerical categorical feature and
then I do my the pre-processing for the
categorical one is a simple in pewter
and one harden quarter and for the
numerical ones I do just simple in
pewter and then I have a pre-processing
that does the column transformer on top
of those and then I have a pipeline I do
my pre-processing and I do random
forests classification I do that and
then the the test accuracy is not too
bad but let's look at the model these
are the feature importances of that
random forest as you can see the random
numerical one is the most important
feature on top of that all the
categorical ones are lower than
numerical ones because inherently I'm
dividing and when I do one [ __ ]
encoding I'm dividing them and the
importance of one categorical feature is
basically the sum of the importances of
all the ones that correspond to it which
you don't see necessarily on the on the
run on the feature importances output of
the random forest so instead of that you
could look at the permutation importance
which is i permutate the data on a
single feature and
look at the performance of the model
does it get worse or not if it doesn't
it means that the model doesn't care
about that feature the good thing about
that is that I can permeate the original
categorical features and then I and then
I applied the pre-processing line so
here I have trained already a random
forest I passed that with some test data
to permutation importance and then I can
repeat that process randomly for 10
times and then I get some confidence
intervals for the importance of each
feature as you can see according to this
metric the random categorical ones and
the random numerical ones are down there
but one thing to to be careful about is
that if you passed your train data the
importances are different and the
numerical one and the categorical ones
are actually a little bit more important
that's because the model has actually
learned from those random ones its
overfitting obviously but it's learning
them the other thing regarding
investigating the models and like
understanding them is the partial
dependence plus how much an output
depends on an input theoretically you
could look at it from using any given
number of input features but visually
you can't really visualize it for more
than one or two features like for two
features you can visualize that on a 3d
plot but more than that it gets hard so
excessive having this is is really
interesting still not in working on it
it means that if you're my hyper
parameter space is huge I cannot do a
grid search on all of it I want to start
and then after the first iteration I
want to cut the ones that have really
low performance I have no hope there and
then I continue from the ones that have
a higher performance and then I do like
at each iteration I cut more of them and
then at the end I get the ones that are
really good it like this enables you to
to explore a much larger parameter space
I had this just in case that was too
fast I wasn't so I can be done thank you
so any question yes thank you for the
talk and the contributions now that I
have a little bit more context about how
you're thinking about setting up the
contribs I could contribute and
implementation factorization machines
and so I was wondering what kind of
process do you go through like what's
differentiating between polylearn
getting in versus like fast FM r pi FM
other libraries that leverage the Sai
kit API for factorization machines we
don't have so your the question kind of
implies that we are we're a gateway and
we don't let some of them in some of
them yes it's more that some of them do
apply to be inside Lincoln trip some of
them don't some there are some amazing
projects out there that from my
perspective it does make some sense for
them to be there but they don't want to
one reason so that it's like some of it
is kind of politics because if you're in
cycling country it means that also I
could learn maintain as have full access
to your repo so in a sense you're kind
of losing ownership on top of that there
are certain requirements like you need
to be documented you need to be pipette
compatible like all of that stuff and
some of them don't want to bother with
that maybe we are not it it's not a big
gateway if you satisfy those conditions
it can be in and if there are multiple
implementations of the same model in in
one space we're OK to ask them a
question yeah and I heard that hello
very good presentation M that there's
going to be sprint how else I could
learn this weekend
so maybe you can tell about that yep
well I'm there I like as an organizer on
there anyway so I'm gonna be at the
table I'm working on scikit-learn and if
people want to contribute I'm more than
happy to to help you set up your machine
or start your first contribution or
continue on your older contributions you
have a question cool I have one just
what very quick one I was wondering how
the imputation functions have been
borrowed from imbalance learn or what is
the difference between oh that's a great
question so one role of the whole
country is to experiment with the API
and with them with the methods so for
example : transformer is something that
was experimented on on SQL and pandas in
Peters - well one one reason that we
started to work on in pewters is that SK
line used to be used heavily in academia
now it is also used in the industry and
academia your data sets are much cleaner
than in industry so now or or it's like
when you go you teach you don't
necessarily assume that your data has
missing values but now it's become more
and more important therefore imputation
is one of those things that it's there's
way more demand on it from the from the
industry side and therefore it's
included but there isn't necessarily a
difference between imbalance land
imputation and this one they're cleaner
like it said like higher level of
standard it has like past those quality
checks but otherwise there's not
necessarily a big difference oh yeah
very quick question what you can you
approach limit yeah thanks a lot for the
presentation quick question on the
explain ability features you showed
partial dependence plots what's the
roadmap in general and features like
that because there I see a big a blank
space in the Python world on those kinds
of features
so when you look at the the the major
goals in the roadmap there the explained
ability and interpret ability of the
models is one of them
pandas integration is another one and
more stable like some changes into the
API is another one and what I mean by
that is that for example the partial
dependence plus they don't necessarily
work with all the models that's like in
the making some of them are already
added and it's in the process it's one
of those things that now we care about
and we focus on so whenever there is a
new contribution then we work on it
there isn't necessarily a list of things
that we have in the queue it's more that
this is a topic that now we care about
and therefore we're gonna like pick on
them and like find things that we can
implement or if there is a contribution
we're gonna focus on that and we
prioritize that I don't think we know
it's coffee break time sorry thank you
very much for the talk